hey gang welcome to the ru garbage
comedy podcast
please make sure you subscribe that way
you get the episodes as they come out
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is
r.u garbage a little show we sit down
with your favorite comedians and we
found out that you're out to be classy
yeah or it's just a big old piece of
trash
i'm your host h foley coming at you on a
beautiful day down here at ant today's
basement she continues to drive us crazy
yeah she's running around the streets
telling everybody
she hit the lottery and she's a
millionaire a year ago
she acted like we weren't even related i
know she sees those patreon numbers
she's something else i'll tell you that
that tooty man she's really something
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me extremely unamused
he is the ceo of are you garbage he's an
international businessman he's my best
pal give it up
for kevin james ryan that was very sweet
hey gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube and as you know those numbers
are
true through the roof man youtube is
[ __ ] cooking also patreon.com those
numbers are i mean
i mean that's what's cooking those
things are [ __ ] yes that's crazy
thank you for everybody joining the
patreon
and then um we have a couple of live
shows coming up atlantic city
uh chicago uh i might be adding a fourth
show in chicago what the [ __ ] that's
crazy chicago and indy get those tickets
it'll be in the description do it baby
and have a nice shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
mr t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen
everybody what up dudes
t-bone how are we doing good buddy yo
new york city greatest city in america
huh
right that's what they say if that's the
case then why would they ever put
[ __ ] salt on fries anywhere you get
them he gets so upset about the little
insanity this guy these kids from
chicago
[ __ ] going on can't take them anywhere
gang we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly incredibly
special guest here with us today this
man is a legendary radio broadcaster
wwe personality and podcaster
he is the co-host of jim and sam on
sirius xm
but the big question anybody's mind
today is he
garbage satellite radio
pro wrestling if i had a saw buck i'm
guessing yes
but that's why we love them give it up
for sam roberts everybody
thank you for having me i'm so glad that
the wwe thing is there
because otherwise it would just be a
bunch of disappointed jim norton fans
right now
oh it's the other guy
it's the other one also he rolled in in
a [ __ ]
customized undertaker denim jacket
everything's so
weak oh dude appreciate it i saw him i
was walking out of the bedroom i saw him
in the hallway i was like oh my god
that is next level [ __ ] new money
trash
is that it was that a gift or how did
you get there did you pay for that
oh no i bought this this is a purchase
this is a purchased item not even worn
going like okay yeah sorry garbage
podcast or where my most garbage this is
my jacket
i thought the undertaker like threw that
seal like like mean joe green in the
[ __ ]
coke commercials go get them
[Laughter]
buddy thank you so much for coming and
staying with us we've been wanting to
have this happen for a long time we're
excited
yeah i'm glad to be in the basement
thank you yeah on the fourth floor
in a high-rise building in midtown um
give us the back story give us the full
deal
new rochelle kid yeah yeah so well
honest
well so i was born in new rochelle in
west chester
we moved to england for a little while
really wow that's a curveball
right and that's a very classy can i
stop it right there
is is is new rochelle considered west
chester
you mean because it's so close to it's
like i think it's west chester it's
delicious
all right it's not upper westchester
okay i'm also so trashy when he said
england i thought that was like
connecticut or something
i'm like i'm like oh you went to like
new london or something
[Laughter]
you went to england proper you went yeah
no no i spent four years living in
england wow
as a kid damn yeah [ __ ] proper royal
parents job
yeah yeah my dad was the prince
[Laughter]
after a couple of weeks yeah yeah wow
what did he do that took him to england
he was an ad exec
really yeah we're talking 80s 90s here
89 88 to 92. so right on that cusp there
right damn right in the sweet spot
brothers and sisters
yeah i have an older sister how old
she's four years older than me so she's
probably
40 41 40 41 gotcha
i mean yeah you should know that's
something you probably should right yeah
like yeah i don't know early 40s correct
i'm not really sure she wasn't a border
i don't know what her name was
so the whole family goes over there to
england all of us yeah four years four
years
in london no outside of london where in
the westchester
in the west in the new roadshow and we
live in westchester new york
we live in surrey england you were in
old rochelle yeah
yeah the original rochelle
the pizza is different was that a nice
was that a nice area in
england yeah yeah it was like a nice
suburban and how
old were you when this happened like i
wasn't like oliver twist if that's what
you're asking like i wasn't like
you know joining a pit pocket so how
long were you a chimney sweep
blowing sawdust and sailors faces
yeah yeah no it was like where the kids
in mary poppins lived that had the
chimney sweep
um how old were you when this happened
this is this is exciting right so we
moved there when i was four five six
seven eight
and then back to the stage so you
thought you were british right right
you don't remember before that do you i
mean like
real little bit right it was just like a
little weird my little brother
started to develop an english accent
yeah really while he was over there yeah
because he went over there
he was bastard until sam beat the [ __ ]
out of him
at the same time we used to like every
summer like
my family's roots are in kentucky oh
okay
england that's a couple kids all over
the place right so every summer we go to
kentucky and then my brother would
develop like
what a southern accent for the week that
we were in kentucky
and then go back to england what the
[ __ ] oh yeah [ __ ]
yeah what did people in england say when
they said uh where are you summering
this year
[Laughter]
paducah ah the island of paducah
just next to santorini i believe yes no
it's uh next to the dog track
route 21. no i think i think my parents
were like really
worried about us becoming british
because they found a private school
that's [ __ ] awesome that's like an
american lesson plan sure yeah there's
an american school
in in england yeah so i mean literally
there's a bunch of fat kids running
around
who's the greatest country in the world
playing dodgeball us versus the world
yeah when i joined the cub scouts
it was in england but it was like boy
scouts of america
it was the same cub scouts as here when
we moved back to the states
school in new rochelle same textbook
really almost the same page
back here it was really this is bonko's
i didn't know we were going down this
road yeah you were in the boy scouts and
that's like in glorious basketball
you're blending in with the local
population
everybody just got guns pointed under
the table yeah yeah the only time
that it stopped being an american school
is uh during operation desert storm
yes you quickly went british so british
they literally sent notices
home give this to your parents and the
notices said don't
send your kids to school wearing
american flag stuff like you normally do
no red white and blue yeah yeah because
like you're a [ __ ] mark dude
you're overseas there's already conflict
goal a war going on
they don't want anything i'd be french
right
right i didn't remember being so worried
i had to tell my mom to put away her
like
you know the ralph lauren sweater that
has the american flag on it that every
moment i was like don't mom
yeah mom don't wear it yeah wait so
you're talking this is
the original desert storm the original
desert storm yeah not iraqi freedom yeah
right
yeah georgia yeah yeah really yeah
that was the 90s early 90s yeah i mean
the brits were involved in that too
wouldn't they
wouldn't they have been a target as well
yeah but i mean like are you looking to
me like i have the [ __ ] answers
like also i was like seven yeah so
yeah well they say that they say that
going abroad anytime there's something
going on just they were like hey don't
have an american flag on your book bag
or whatever and it's awesome who travels
like that [ __ ] that i'm coming in hot
yeah i don't give a [ __ ] oakley's on the
back of your hat
y'all got a mcdonald's oakley's in my
seatbelt extender for the airplane
becoming an american baby yeah england
was a wild place though
like every morning the school bus would
drive us into school
and right outside the gates of the
school was this like
family of people who lived in caravans
and had like wild dogs
gypsies yeah yeah spikeys gypsies
gypsies
literally gypsy and we go like what
what's with the people in the
caravans that live outside our school
ice cream truck
those are the gypsies yeah yeah yeah
then you just it was it just let them be
gypsies went on and still kind of did i
remember i went to ireland in like the
earth like 2008 or nine and there was
like just proper
that was like still an issue right
gypsies you don't bother them
they won't bother you yeah but don't
bother them yeah don't say anything
no you just the gypsies are there that's
where the school is there we go
that's [ __ ] frightening holy [ __ ]
this might be the i mean we've had some
wild upbringings on this show
dude living in an american
world in england from kentucky is like
a bananas line yeah whose roots are in
kentucky
your fathers both so which they may be
cousins i don't know
same house actually weird both my
parents
were born in kentucky okay both their
parents moved them to detroit
when they were kids separately
separately yeah they didn't know each
other they weren't
yeah they weren't gypsies no they
weren't japanese it's [ __ ] strange
but like when the
when a bunch of jobs started popping up
in the in the car factories
uh-huh in detroit i guess a lot of
people are sure yeah that makes sense
yeah yeah that makes sense all right my
grandparents on both sides
were kind of a part of that whole thing
wow yeah that's not then your parents
met in detroit
they met in detroit uh-huh yeah then
they
my dad moved to l.a and uh
this guy's all over the place i mean
dude but here's the thing this is what's
so crazy about it
advertising late 80s early 90s
his dad was a [ __ ] sharp guy yeah and
probably made a little bit of cash
okay so this is my dad i mean if you're
going to england yeah if you're changing
countries for your job yeah
yeah yeah you're making some cases
there's no podcast in england asking me
to fly
no way i can't afford something he had
to do good
yeah so his gimmick was even as a
younger guy
he's like whenever when you want to open
a new branch
in this other country in this other
space let me go open it for you
let me be that guy i'm going to need a
cost of living increase
yeah you're going to need to move me and
and you know and that's how we'll do it
so
company he was working for in detroit
moves him to los
angeles he's just kind of i think he and
my mom were casually dating so he's kind
of on the business side of advertising
yeah
he's not doing the he's not coming up
with like the nike swoop or anything
like that
not that i know him if he had nike swoop
money he would not
be sitting next to us yeah i know that
much yeah like
the undertaker jacket was a stretch okay
like
so so he moves to
l.a he gets a cold
and now like he gets sick when he's in
l.a and nobody's there with him
so he calls my mom back in detroit and
he goes look
i'm sick will you come to l.a and marry
me
what wow he didn't have anybody take
care of him that's like a very 19
you know 1920s i'm sick i have the fever
will you marry me and take care of my
face
mr roberts pulling the trigger early
hey i sprained my ankle you want to have
five kids
and so my mom's looking around detroit
and she's like yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah she's like stamping a hood of
a model
yeah let's get the [ __ ] out of here yeah
my mom was rosie the riveter
and she's like done with that life you
know just hear the shift bell go
[Laughter]
all right that's it i'm outta here i'm
going to los angeles to get married
to a sick man so she moves to l.a and
they get married in l.a
all right they move
from l.a to australia
shut up you're lying yeah they spent 11
years together before they had kids
they go from l.a i don't know if i'm
going to get the australian
spots in the right order but i think
it's la
to melbourne australia to open another
place
yup then to sydney he sounds like he's
got people after him
this guy's got something ain't right
he's just spinning a globe and making
decisions yeah
this is like catch me if you can
the cold was actually two flesh wounds
we always had two bathrooms one was for
us and one was the tub that he put all
the uh toy planes in
he had to kill he could make his check
get the labels off yeah and then after
sydney they moved to adelaide australia
okay
then from adelaide they moved to
brussels
jesus brussels they moved to argentina
what did what argentina stop stop stop
stop
there's no way he's not cis yeah
something there's
nowhere yeah yeah i'm in the advertising
agency
first of all there's no brand that's in
all of those places yeah you know what i
mean
there's no consumer product that crosses
that many boundaries i mean i'm almost
positive at least one of those spots
doesn't even have advertising yeah oh
yeah
like you know they're not even uh this
is like what the 80s
or so 70s 70s yeah yeah something's
going on
it's wherever like a government was
overthrown or something at the internet
yet
i just opened up the yugoslavia office
doing pretty good at any point growing
up did you see your dad disassemble a
gun blindfolded
yeah for advertising
you know when he has meetings
holy [ __ ] yeah and he [ __ ] did it so
then they have my sister
in argentina okay but when they're in
argentina
it's like uh uh war times there's like
people with machine guns on every corner
like it's auckland wars i guess so i
don't know whatever whatever was going
on there
it was a scary time and my mom was like
i can't
raise a baby with guys with machine guns
pointed at me everywhere because she's
insane
wait hold on sorry again go ahead so he
happened to be in argentina in the early
years
when there was a proxy war happening
yeah yeah
where there's advertising
you see commercials and the like make
sure to drink coke
[Laughter]
yeah i'm sorry i'm gonna cut you off but
okay so your sister's born
now is this indicative of anybody else
in in your family
or are they all back in on the porch in
kentucky house in kentucky yeah
everybody else is in kentucky or
michigan
and uh or moscow yeah
so that's when they're like all right
all right my mom insists we got to stop
this uh
the whole racket sure this is nuts let's
let's assume aliases
let's pick a space let's stop stop
running guns and settle down
so i'll get new passports take a shot at
this thing
yeah and that's when they get to
westchester new york
and that's when they're like okay this
is gonna be our spot
and then i guess
six years later probably is when my dad
was like one more trip
we're going to england one last job one
more they need a wheel man
one more run yeah and you know it really
was suspicious because i remember
three years into the england trip mm-hmm
i remember him sitting down he's like uh
all right you ready to move back to the
states i'm like yeah it sounds great
pack your bag i'll get you new toys and
i'm like okay like he sat me down to
have that conversation with me i'm like
yeah it's gonna be great
and then uh and that because we didn't
have any of the like all the toys were
late getting to the uk mcdonald's sucked
in the uk like it was terrible oh that
must
have suck terrible like the happy meals
didn't have toys half the time so it's
not the right it's
like brits aren't a jolly people yeah i
mean right
so like a month later we're still in
england
and i was like dad i thought we were
moving back home
and he like with the frustration that
only a dad can have that can't explain
what's going on to his kid he goes
well we're not doing that
all right english is the spot then yeah
a lot of clear big guy
loud and clear holy [ __ ] so we're not
that off base
by suspecting he might have done
something else
i mean i don't have all the answers like
you're asking me all these questions
that's the stuff
or anything that's what i want to know
from an advertising company how does
that thought cross your mind
no i think he's in advertising
trade them good uh
[Laughter]
were the flights above radar no
[Laughter]
who goes back on a submarine
[Laughter]
it's an ocean how else are you gonna get
across it
all that traffic up top no way no no no
no no no damn put this fake mustache on
your sister to get in the car
here's an ad you want an ad helix send
me a mattress
forget about this bozo i mean talk about
recommendation here you won't stop
talking about it send one for uncle hank
gang if you don't know helix you got to
get involved they're
unbelievable helix sleep okay has a quiz
that you take it takes two minutes to
complete
to find out your body type so they can
get a mattress
that goes with you perfectly oh yeah
there's no guessing games nope
take the quiz you find out what
mattresses need they got soft mattresses
they have hard mattresses
they even have mattresses for plus size
sleepers
come on which the big man needs you
ain't built for regular mattresses
nope ah they were uh the good folks over
at helix were kind enough to send me and
my wife one we took the quiz
and we were matched with the twilight
model mattress queen size
one to go king went queen um could you
have one king
yeah yeah they would have sent you a
king these guys are good guys
i do i've never i've had trouble
sleeping i've always had cheap
mattresses i've never had an expensive i
was like hand-me-downs whatever's
an old roommate left it i'm sleeping on
it this is my first proper
bought a mattress like a good mattress
it's a game changer you don't know what
you're
you don't know what you don't know
that's that old saying i didn't know
what i was missing out on until i
stepped on a helix
next thing you know i'm johnny helix i
love the thing
so if you're looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you order the mattress
that you're matched to the mattress
comes right to your door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to the mattress store again also
there's a pandemic going on who
wants to go to a mattress store what are
you doing what are you doing you're
rolling around in public mattresses
talking to helix
no thank you helix is awesome but you
don't need to take my word for it helix
was awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick for 2020 by gq
and wired magazine yikes that's
impressed baby just go to helixsleep.com
garbage take their two minute quiz and
they'll match you with a customized
mattress that'll give you the best sleep
of your life they have a 10-year
warranty and you get to try it for a
hundred nights
risk-free baby fantastic it's awesome
they'll even pick it up if you don't
like it but you will
helix sleep is offering our listeners of
are you garbage 200
off mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners
at helixsleep.com you're saving 200
bucks if you buy it using our promo code
who hunter can they send you two pillows
who pillows
that's helixsleep.com you're saving 200
bucks
you'll be losing money not to buy if
you're if you're if you're looking for a
mattress this is a no-brainer i like it
that's helix sleep.com
garbage for up to 200 off and two free
pillows
gang this podcast is sponsored by better
help oh yeah
is there something in your life that's
kind of holding you back maybe keeping
you from being happy
you got to get involved with better help
betterhelp will assess your needs
and match you with your own licensed
professional
therapist you can start communicating
with one within 48 hours
it's not a crisis hotline it's not a
self-help hotline
it is professional counseling done
securely online in many areas
the service is available to clients
worldwide yeah guys if you've never
tried therap talk therapy before uh take
a look at it give it a shot
it's helped me uh greatly over the past
few years
i know when i was struggling in comedy
and stuff like that when i first moved
to new york i started talking to
somebody and
it really really changed my outlook on
life and helped me kind of
take inventory and realize who i am what
i was doing whole nine yards
i can't recommend it enough recommend it
enough you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video
or phone session so you'll never have to
sit uncomfortable in a waiting room
like you would with traditional therapy
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available
if you do need it better help want you
to start living happier today
visit their website and check out the
reviews from everybody uh from previous
customers
visit betterhelp.com garbage that's
betterhelp help and join over the 1
million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health uh and get help from an
experienced professional
in fact so many people have been using
betterhelp that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
look at that
yeah special offer for ru garbage
listeners uh you get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
garbage one more time baby 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
garbage gang spring is in full bloom oh
yeah
summer is right around the corner
knocking on the door knocking on the
door it's time to get back
out there and start doing the things
that you love to do
before the pandemic and let me tell you
something what you're going to want to
do
you're going to want to take a bespoke
post on all your adventures oh yeah they
got a brand new lineup of
essential boxes of awesome
a box of awesome collection that they
have
that's guaranteed to upgrade your life
so whether you're going out there to
tame the wilderness whether you want to
take your
your home bar and make it more
professional bespoke post
only sends guys the best stuff every
single month no matter what you're into
box of awesome has you covered from
style and grooming goods
they got bar ware they got cooking tools
and they got
outdoor gear box of awesome
as a collection for every single part of
your life
they do it they got it bottom line is
it's cool guy
[ __ ] that's what it is got me a sweet
tent yeah it's [ __ ] that you're like oh
that'd be awesome to have boom you got
it
with with bespoke post baby it's cool
guys [ __ ] they sent it right to you they
sent us a box we got a knife we got a
tent we got a duffel bag
we got a we got a hammock a hammock a
camping blanket it's
awesome so to get started take the quiz
at box of awesome.com your answers will
help
them pick the right box for box of
awesome for you
uh they release new black shoes they
release new boxes every month across a
ton of different categories
so whatever you're into they got it it's
free to sign up
you can skip a month whenever you want
or cancel any
time each box want to hear the rub i
love it you gotta get yourself
each box only costs 45 bucks but how
much is it 45 clams
45 beans how much stuff is in there yeah
over 70
worth of stuff what are we doing what
are you doing i mean i don't know how
these guys are turning a profit what are
we doing
guys here it is you get 20 off your
first monthly box when you sign up at
box of awesome dot
com and use our promo code garbage you
know it i know it
box of awesome.com promo code garbage at
checkout one more time baby get a pen
get a paper write it down that's box of
awesome.com
promo code garbage for 20 off your first
box
now back to the show no matter where we
were
new york england wherever yeah every
july 4th week we were in paducah
kentucky
they probably that was probably pretty
good july 4th in paducah kentucky yeah
it's great
yeah it was great lemonade you guys
farsi i can see
you guys are like kings and queens
coming home they probably didn't know
what to do
yeah i can't i'm a world like legit
world travelers
i like i took it for granted i guess as
a kid because you don't whatever is
presented to you is normal yeah yeah of
course
but yeah i mean i can't imagine the [ __ ]
they were just talking behind our backs
oh yeah they must have just
hated us yeah rich kids from england
showing up at paducah and that was
probably exciting for you to get back to
the u.s soil for that week like you said
the toys the
walmart walmart the tv shows the
cartoons yeah
you know in england they called him
teenage mutant hero turtles oh
the [ __ ] get out ninja's too vile
everybody's talking about cancel culture
now i'm like please
please yeah teenage waves teenage mutant
heroes teenage mutant hero turtles and
they
did redid the song you know teenage
mutant hero turtles
he's gotta be kidding me they've been
raping and pillaging for [ __ ] six
years
right dude they got yeah they've been
dipping their ink and [ __ ]
balls on them yeah
yeah that's a [ __ ] tale geez yeah
yeah and that only takes me to like nine
years i know that right that's the crazy
part
so then did it get somewhat normal after
that after that yeah
did your mom work no he's definitely
there's no way he wasn't [ __ ]
working for the company yeah how many
languages does he speak
he knows i mean he speaks whatever it
depends what country we're in i've never
asked him how many ladies speaks it he
yeah he can get enough to get by
no matter where we are what i don't even
think of that
enough to get by no matter where we are
and then he has all these little like um
i'm like yeah i got this adidas uh
tracksuit or whatever
he's like adidas yeah adidas
he's like no body and adidas yeah and
i'm like where were you
that you no we're good i know
[Laughter]
jesus christ that's whoo
so you get back yeah you've done all
this [ __ ] and you're what nine
ten years old yeah so now you're
starting like you're you're a little kid
right so is this when you start soaking
up uh like you know you really
were you would you say you were more
enthused about american culture
coming back here does that make sense
you know what i mean
yeah yeah like it's it because when we
were in england it was like a treat
all of it right like whatever bits of
america that you could get
out you know what i mean like you like
the whole school was designed
to mock like to look like an american
school right everything was like we're
trying to get as much of america as we
can so yeah once
once i was back here i was like yeah
this is this is
full throttle baby let's do it yeah is
that when you started getting into
wrestling and stuff like that was that
around no i was into wrestling in the uk
all the way over there yeah because they
had the wwe was
was was over there yeah i mean
as early as i can remember yeah it's
awesome yeah they've been doing their
thing that wwe yeah
i i was excited that you were coming in
to because i was uh i was a kid of wwf
right because i'm i'm older than you
guys i'm 45. so
you know hulk hogan [ __ ] junkyard dog
that whole saturday thing
[ __ ] i was i was i was i like how you
named hulk hogan is like we didn't know
who hulk
oh man tell me more before i'm from
before your time you know i'm talking
back in the day
when i was growing up it was john cena
yeah
[Laughter]
i was more of an irs kind of guy
you know what i meant i was excited so
then
where did you guys settle in now in new
rochelle single-family home
apartment what was this no we had it
yeah we had a single family house
nice yeah all right yeah very cool it
was the same house we left we rented it
out while we were gone
for the four years and we came back to
it damn
passive revenue stream
dude your dad's a [ __ ] shark yeah
yeah this is a sharp guy
my dad always made money he'd never
spent money yeah really
never spent i'm finding out that's what
you gotta do yeah cause now we're making
it i'm spending it quicker than i ever
have
right you're like it's a write-off and
you're like hey you still it's still yes
it doesn't mean they give it back to you
yeah
he was trying to explain that to me dude
i feel like we're robbing every
restaurant that we go to
when he takes out the corporate card
he's got running
he literally panics like the irs is
standing next to him he's like whose
money is this
i'm like it's fine just listen to me
i only had the wings i only had the
wings
i know sam's dead man so
somewhat normal childhood yeah yeah
yeah you know moving multinational
espionage normal
yeah yeah yeah and then
after that normal you know
i mean i wasn't an outdoorsy kid yeah i
was out in the cub scouts by fifth grade
because it was i mean once they were
like hey let's go camping i'm like whoa
hey i'll build the car maybe i'll do the
derby yeah yeah if i would derby i'm
good because i painted up like you know
wrestling cars like this is the macho
man car this is going to be
but like after that they were like and
especially when they started kind of
creeping in with the hazing yeah like
i'd watch when like it was hazing
yeah when you get to like boy scout
level like sixth grade and they're like
oh you got to prove that you could tie
this knot yeah i'm not sleeping in the
woods with a guy with a mustache
i don't think so all right let's get
into some more you garbage questions
i kind of want to go uh straight up the
middle here uh you want to do back then
or do you want to do now because he
lives in the suburbs now as well he
lives in the suburbs now
uh i'd like to know a little bit more
about once he got here and got settled
okay
because new rochelle you know state of
new york we can wash away international
travel pretty quickly
yeah i used to work in new rochelle
there's parts of it that are a little
dicey
yeah yeah there's a there's a real clear
halfway point yes there's a mcdonald's
there that looks like [ __ ] syria dude
it is a tough one
that's my mcdonald's yeah i mean i went
to birthday parties holy [ __ ] all right
so what was the name of the street that
you grew up on
i don't think i want to say the name of
the street i grew up they're not there
they're near enough yeah yeah fair
enough yeah
yeah how about the name of the grocery
store the well
it was uh it started as the finest
and then became stop and shop stop and
shops are
okay the finest i don't know what the i
don't know it was the finest before it
was the stoppage shop it was
this is the best one over here the
finest sounds like some guy really you
know making it sound better
right yeah the finest the finest but it
wasn't like uh
it wasn't one of those like uh you know
gourmet sure
sort of like whole foods yeah yeah yeah
the [ __ ] carts with the locks on the
wall yeah the finest generally doesn't
have to say
that they are the finest yes right
exactly
wegmans isn't being like hey we're
awesome they're just going hey we're
wegmans
we let the products be yeah so you know
what i mean yeah the finest
yeah by the way first guest ever to not
want to give up the streets no there's
been two or three
yeah yeah yeah that's the people that
still the people that still live
all sudden the blow dart just hits me
yeah i do have that
well it's also like tell tens of
thousands of people where your family is
it's like you know what i mean like what
the [ __ ] when people move out of it
i assume they moved on from there i love
though that you're already getting to
the point where i'm like you got a lot
of questions over there
you ask a lot of questions
what do you work for the school
newspaper your dad opens the door
all right go ahead kip um i kind of want
to know we can jump back and forth a
little bit now you have uh do you have a
garage now single family home
now yeah we have a well yeah we have a
garage
but we can't fit the car in it it's like
a real small garage
isn't it it's okay it's attached to the
house okay
is it wait is it you can't fit it just
because it's too small for a car or you
just have so much [ __ ] in there
it's it's real small for a car yeah it's
a real small garage but it is
a garage attached to the house okay i
don't know if i can picture that
that's more of a shed i feel like that's
an attache
it's probably closer to a shed if i
could compare it to the garage i grew up
with i would
put this in the shed is this an older
home
like so we were told that the house that
we lived in
uh was once the servant's quarters to
the house
next door to us the house you live in
now yeah
was the service quarter's house yeah
okay yeah that's awesome
it's like uh smallest house on a nice
street
okay you know where you're like wait
what is that house it's right there
yeah yeah yeah we can't afford anything
oh hold on yeah
kids we just got a new zip code yeah
okay okay that's awesome do you have a
do you have a fridge in the
shed garage currently or no we have a
freezer
okay like one of those deep freezers
yeah okay classy classic
meats it was for breast milk initially
weird okay you only got two kids
yeah no now it ends up it would be good
for meat
like if we hunted and stuff like that
but it ends up just being home to like
big costco boxes of eggos hey
anything wrong with that i'll give you
that not too shabby freezer burn in
there or no
keep it nice yeah no freezer bro yeah
yeah quite a bit of those deep those
things
those things will freeze and burn like
four hours oh yeah those things could
get cooking
quick and when i see freezer burn it's
one of those things where you go like no
i mean i guess there's just freezer
burning
yeah you know i wouldn't even start to
fathom how to
but i've eaten eggos that look like
they've been in like [ __ ] ice again
you smash them over the sink and get the
get the ice cause you put them in the
toaster it'll melt
that weird taste though you can you can
tell it's tough a couple winters in
there
why is this soggy you need a lot of
angelimo on that thing yeah dude garage
freezers run on liquid nitrogen there is
nothing colder you can keep dna in there
if you wanted to yeah they got ted
williams in it he did
he did keep dna yeah yeah yeah that's
funny
okay [ __ ] uh what do you got foley what
do i got all right popping around here
um uh anybody in your immediate family
have a birthday on a holiday
uh any christmas babies or july 4th
babies
no excellent no do you share a birthday
with anybody in your family
no okay nice uh we got one strike
against you so far okay it's
kid's coming up classy all right what uh
i mean the jacket says
a lot just let's not forget about the
jacket okay
that was before the question started but
those are the freshest nikes that have
ever been in the studio it's the
dichotomy of man
he's got a kentucky upbringing he has an
embroidered an
embroidered undertaker jack i know but
it's pretty sweet i'm saying it's sick
it's sick it's good yeah yeah and you
see the back of it it's a big picture of
the undertaker
just show the camera come on we got to
show it
that's [ __ ] sweet dude uh i like the
undertaker yeah
we got that i thought you're more of a
cane man
um what uh what'd you get on your sats
there you go
13.
that english education did well i'm
right okay i'll tell you what happened
there
went to syracuse i had my dad take him
for me yeah so
you should when yeah 13 20.
i remember you could have stopped at 13.
you were shocked yeah yeah
you're the smartest guy in the room
right now because
i maybe it's 12 30. still
still okay i'm gonna say 12 30 because
there's no i think the deal was my dad
said
you could go as 11 50. and still be the
smartest guy in the building
12 30 is where i'm gonna stay okay
because my dad said
if you cause my parents were convinced
that i was smarter than
any piece of paper was letting on okay
that i was sitting
that i was not sure achieving to my
potential and that i needed incentive i
was an incentive based learner
okay so wwe was coming to town
it was king of the ring
raw and smackdown in a row
one night after the other my dad said if
you can break 1300 on your sats
i'll figure out a way i'll get you front
row seats to all three of those shows
what that's going to call it some favors
yeah that's what he's going to do
and i didn't know how he's playing i'm
going to talk to a sheik or something
right
somebody in abu dhabi is getting sitting
next to a saudi prince
yeah because i'd never been anywhere
near the front row i was like nuts and
is this at the garden
no this it was definitely long island
was where king of the ring was
so they're probably all in long island
probably at the uh nassau coliseum
uh so i'm going like okay and so when
the grade comes back and i get at 12
30 my parents are like like my dad
had this look like he just got saved by
the skin
they had no faith a deal's a deal that
anywhere near 1300 was gonna come
he was like all right so he ended up
getting me like you know section 100
tickets to king of the ring
and he was like all right that's good
for 12 30. damn but yeah
okay 12 30 good 12 30. and what did you
study at syracuse what was your major
i ended up leaving with a sociology
degree okay
right so i don't like the way you said
that i ended up leaving
they didn't give it to me i took it
that's all i could grab out of the
dean's office they were closing in on me
i guess when you got that many beers in
you [ __ ] focus
so that was another moment right like i
applied to nyu
early decision and i didn't get it i
love the confidence
the early decision early decision nyu
let's
go yeah and i didn't get in and i was
like super bummed and i never
like my parents the way they were
talking to me it was like like we're
sensitive to how you're feeling right
now but like
what did you think what was going to
happen like where
where did you see that going because
this is exactly
the letter that we thought you were
packing yeah yeah yeah so when i got
into syracuse
i mean i i it's one thing when your
parents are like happy for you but when
they're literally
shocked like this must be a mistake you
can read it all on their face and i'm
and that's the face that i got from them
so i tried to get into broadcasting
school
into a new house at syracuse okay and uh
is that a good program it's the best
okay
dick clark uh everybody everybody it's
the best broadcasting school there is
i didn't get into it but they got
one of those bozos look at you now yeah
that's right so they let me into the the
kind of broader college of arts and
sciences
we'll let you [ __ ] around in the corner
for a couple of years yeah yeah
and they go hey here's the good news if
you can get a 3.5 gpa
anywhere in syracuse
you can you can meet dwink and dink
do you like sugar ray
[Laughter]
this guy's working all on bribes
everything everything
they go if you get a 3.5 gpa you can
transfer into into new house
broadcasting school
no questions asked nice i was like okay
so i got the syracuse i'm like that's my
plan
one week i was like that's not gonna
happen nope that's not gonna happen
so then i found out there's this other
film major
art film not like broadcaster film where
they like teach you how to make films
but not how to make money making films
okay right yeah
so i was like okay that's the what i'm
going to do because anybody could get
into that sure
so after a year in syracuse i
transferred over there
i did that for two years i guess and
then i ended up
interning for opium anthony okay never
heard of him
right yeah so i was gonna that was your
first job
at your first radio job yeah yeah this
is in the summer summer between
my third and fourth year at syracuse
okay i say that because they wanted me
to do a fifth year
because i was a year late getting into
that film program i told you about god
right right
so after the internship one of the guys
there was like ah we would have kept you
on for another semester but you're going
you're going to syracuse and i'm like oh
i really made an impression on these
guys
i can't i mean maybe i can go back to
syracuse for a year but i can't go back
to syracuse for two years
sure so i started going through the
course catalog and
i was like okay what what classes have i
taken i started listing all the classes
i took
what is a major like what constitutes
man
a major are you asking me right you got
the wrong guy yeah
and i was like well i took all these
sociology classes in the beginning
sure what can i get right what i have
what's the fastest exit
can i send a major together bro dude if
i take a year's worth of sociology
classes does that a major make
does that a major make and the answer is
yes yeah
so i go on a computer and i just start
switching myself out of all these
classes
i like it half the year goes by and i'm
taking all these sociology classes and i
go to my
did you bounce this off anybody before
no okay i go this way
this is because opening anthony showed
interesting they showed it the slightest
amount so it's like
and i go like i'm gonna drop out of
school this is the height of this is
they're big
right they're like i mean they're huge
at this point and i go i'm gonna drop
out of school my dad was like no problem
but the rent is super expensive to live
in a house
whose house his house in new rochelle in
his house
i played hardball yeah he's gonna charge
me a lot of rent if i'm gonna
drop out of school and you're probably
in turn you'd be interning at no money
right for free so i'm like okay so
dropping out of school is not
part of the game here he's throwing a
number at you no i mean he just made it
clear like you can't afford it that's
the number
yeah whatever you can afford it's five
dollars
yeah yeah so it's like okay so i went i
i pieced together my major
i did that for the first half of the
year then i went to my advisor
still in the film program by the way and
i was like look dude like
he's like what the [ __ ] are you doing
you're in 14 sociology classes right now
it's like i need you to sign this paper
that gets me out of the film program
i have not taken any of these classes
and i took all sociology classes
i just need you to sign the paper it's
done and he was like like he's pissed
because he was like i'm the sign and he
signed the paper
i got the rest of my sociology credits
damn and i got out of syracuse
is that trash i i don't know he makes
garbage i mean he went through college
like he had five dollars at the dollar
menu yeah
i gotta get a meal here can you wave the
taxes
yeah yeah it's like by the letter of the
law like yeah you said
a dollar is a dollar it says dollar menu
it doesn't say dollar plus tax menu
right yeah no drink just a quarter cup
please
that's exactly buddy all right
so and then we went to work for ona then
went to work for o a for free for a
while and then for
a little bit of money and then you know
yeah yeah so do you let you stay in the
house is that what you were were you
operating out of once i got the degree
he yeah he didn't charge me he didn't
charge me rent yeah
hmm man yeah oh this guy's a
i mean his whole family his whole
family's all over the place to be honest
uh okay yeah what are your brothers and
sisters they
uh my sister works in advertising
my sister's in the family business
he worked for the company okay yeah and
my brother works in
uh film development ish
okay yeah and um yeah a kid's a hustler
yeah yeah that's a mover and i know man
i know i've never heard of anybody doing
that
i just failed out of school well that's
when i went down with the ship
yeah yeah that's nuts yeah i always like
to you know
like i think there's a way i can still
win here
without having to play this game that
was it i could still win this thing
you did it yeah it was a hail mary let
me [ __ ] there's
there's five seconds left now i'm a
sociologist
with a minor in criminal justice
yeah and by the way because syracuse has
such a great broadcasting school they're
like
everybody seriously now you're probably
the new house huh and i'm like ah you
know you don't tell anybody that you
didn't go to new house
did they ever come back and kind of does
syracuse recognize you as like a huge
broadcaster
nothing really really i was [ __ ]
[ __ ] let me tell you something
during march madness they put out the
101
most famous graduates of syracuse you're
not on there nowhere near
who's number one i i there were names on
that list that you didn't know
not by a mile the only thing i knew
about those names is that my name was
bigger
crazy yeah damn man you're never a hero
in your hometown right
right you got to leave for them so they
can love you [ __ ] them that's insane you
should
be on that list just for the way you
[ __ ] finagled your degree
[Laughter]
yeah they can't have me going back for
commencement because i'll let the kids
know you know you don't have to
hey listen yeah what do you got three
art credits already you're an artist
you're cutting deals all right you
trading me two criminal justice
credits you traded me two english
credits and then boom you're a doctor
right right you got beat out by a kicker
for the steelers
and what did he do for syracuse i mean
and you've been
i mean you've had you've had a proper
broadcasting career legendary
last 20 20 years probably right just the
fact that i've survived in the game
is nuts come on i mean you were on one
of the biggest show the biggest radio
shows
of all time right they were huge oh and
hey yeah yeah
and now you're on [ __ ] are you
garbage come on which is also the
biggest everybody's new favorite podcast
by the way
patent pending i mean have you seen
these youtube numbers you guys are
getting there
don't get me started on a patreon that
thing's cooking
don't get me started on it don't start
out with me say oh
money do you guys go out to eat a lot
well i mean we haven't first
can i come with you uh
not for the last year obviously not for
the last year and you know i mean i
think uh
having a couple kids threw a monkey
wrench into that but before that
yeah dinner and a movie was a pretty
regular is it a pretty hectic household
is everybody moving and shaking pretty
much constantly yeah yeah lots of
movement in the household yeah okay
um if you did go out to eat do you refer
to this item as appetizers or starters
what would you use what terminology
would you use are they appetizers
or are they starters appetizer
just gets clean yeah appetizing do you
know how to tie a tie
yeah not only wait wait wait don't
forget about my wwe experience putting
suits on yeah
i know how to tie a bow tie whoa wow
do you own it you own a bow tie i own a
couple bucks and you know how to tie
them not the clips like no no no no no
no the real bowties
i'm i'm not clan i'm trash i'm i'm you
know
less trash than foley and i c i can't
for the life of me taya bow tie oh yeah
that is like tough
that's a tough task i sat down on a
couch
you know a week before the first time i
did wrestlemania
and just sat there tying and tying and
tying and tying until it's like
until you got second nature that's
[ __ ] class dude dude
you're really coming up close well it is
like
hey man this guy knows how to tie a bow
tie oh how do you learn that
wrestlemania
yeah sure like there is this like forget
the jacket
we're talking about a billion dollar
industry here thank you
thank you long-standing [ __ ] fine
american company
thank you all right thank you
entertaining people all around the world
thank you again
for low budget i don't see that no it's
not local wrestling federation
yeah you're not at the armory calling
the match never heard of a rock
huh have you ever heard of him hulk
hogan
ever hear that guy back in my way
hacksaw jim
duggan your honor
yeah okay are you currently in a beef
with a neighbor
no okay i'm on good standards with the
neighbor okay
yep we didn't i did has was in some
dicey time i wasn't sure about him
when we first moved in now everything's
good
kosher kid loves him so when your kid
loves the neighbor it's like you're okay
in my book
interesting um you or your wife
in the last uh year or so have you ever
made chex mix
made checks making chex mix no okay is
that classy or trashy that's if you're
making chex miss
classy garbage oh yeah yeah well i
figure well okay
every [ __ ] shitty communion party
that i went to from [ __ ] buy one
that's a new thing dude if you're back
in the day you're a [ __ ] bozo if
you're making your own chex mix that's
why it's
okay so buy and it's classier no chex
mix in general stinks i understand
you're garbage i would tell you you
don't make it like the gentleman
mr roberts like sir sam over here yeah
yeah although i do remember you know my
mom would make a banana pudding
and i remember having like a a
girlfriend come over the house and my
mom made her
her banana pudding famous banana bread
right and and
my girlfriend at the time she was like
oh man where'd you get this recipe and
my mom was like oh i was passed down
from my mom like oh it's my grandma's
recipe and blah blah and as soon as my
girlfriend
left the house she was like that
recipe's on the back of the nilla wafers
box
that's the secret family recipe i like
it keep up appearances rule number one
it's family business got that off a box
of ribs
who puts nilla wafers in banana pudding
if it's not the nilla wafers restaurant
right yeah yeah shout out to banana
pudding though
big fan no yeah uh
anyone in your family smoke a pipe my
dad
currently or ever let's go ever my dad
spent a period of time smoking a pipe
he did he's gotta unwind after all the
torture
after a long day of pulling out people's
fingernails yeah i feel like you had a
piano in your house growing up that
didn't have piano wiring
your dad was cultured right yeah oh yeah
yeah i lived in [ __ ] 15 countries
he's got to be
yeah my dad to this day still has a
handle bar mustache
he had like grown up the wax for the
mustache
never used a can of shaving cream always
the brush and the dish
yep it's a [ __ ] gentleman and uh and
yeah and he smoked a pipe for a period
of time
hmm did he shave with a straight razor
or with like uh
no he well probably the metal ones like
the real the real no he would use like
gillette except i think it was when his
company was advertising with gillette
like i said the guy's not freebies oh
there you go he's not spending cash
if we can get some free razors at the
house
shout out to hello fresh everybody
[Laughter]
um hmm oh you can go sorry uh do you
currently have a pocket knife on you
no i think a guy like this this caliber
is gonna be walking around with a
[ __ ] swiss army knife
i thought you were going to be do better
right so did i thought you're going to
be real trash
okay uh i thought you showered in
mountain dew
that's honestly what i was expecting um
okay if you
have you this is a two-part question
have you ever owned a ping-pong table a
pool
table or a bumper pool table if so what
room were they in in the house
no we've never owned any of those things
okay i mean
come on we used them in kentucky a lot
like the
the resorts the resort it was called the
resort
you didn't stay with family you guys
stayed at a resort the whole family
would go into the
resort it was like a motel by other
standards wait so your family was from
kentucky
well they were also don't forget they
were displaced to michigan too
so kind of everybody back in kentucky
they would all meet back
and they would all get rooms at this
motel
but bottom line almost everybody but you
was vacationing in basically their
hometown
no no people still coming forward a lot
two i mean look some were coming from
michigan
others were like they i think one came
from nebraska
but yeah i mean look you weren't on a
beach it was what i'm saying it was not
a beach yeah
it was not a tropical locale
yeah no cow no what did the resort offer
they had a pool it pulled the ground
you know kentucky summers get real hot
so they had like a a playground
but everything was made of metal oh so
so everything you touched it would just
grill
remember that yeah you know they did not
care in the 80s and 90s about playground
safety they didn't know anything you
could
you could fry eggs oh my god yeah and
they had a restaurant there
they always knew we were coming every
year like they were like oh this is
i think you know the roberts are showing
up yeah this is it they're throwing some
cash this is it they're back from
argentina and they're throwing some
pesos yeah throw in some extra hush
puppies the roberts
hush puppies were huge man hush puppies
were huge down there
and sorry go ahead this is big did your
family wear
matching t-shirts when at the resort no
like robert's reunion that's a great
question 1992.
no but then there was a wider family
reunion
oh right so it was like this family
reunion at the resort
was just the immediate family my dad's
brothers and sisters and their kids and
that's okay
right then there was the bigger reunion
they're coming out of the woodwork right
when you got the bigger reunion that's
not you we're not going down a good road
here
this is where like cousin pudding would
be there that's a real guy
that's a guy i would have figured it was
a girl oh that's a guy i would have
figured pudding was a girl
right let's put and do i don't know he
said
he has a good time he's a happy guy he's
hanging out i just want to say after the
tale that you have told us and the
deflection of the questions
the fact that we're like in the 50th
minute here and you just go ahead and
give yourself
up for without uncle pudding cousin
cousin technically he's my dad's cousin
so he's i don't know if he's my great
man
this guy's trash cousin
hey everybody gets a mulligan okay
[Laughter]
yeah yeah that was the like that was the
big like
robert's extended like i don't know how
i'm related to this person
that's why family reunions are [ __ ]
you should never be meeting a family
member at a family reunion like right
who are you right why the [ __ ] am i
meeting you then it doesn't matter
yeah if i saw any of those people on the
street today head down i
yeah i [ __ ] hate them we went to one
and after like an hour i was like yo
let's go get the [ __ ] out of here this
is a room full of strangers was there
robert's t-shirts going around at the
extended one or no
i think at the extended one there were
okay so at the extended one
at one point i'm sure there were
t-shirts you know i can't like picture
it but i'm sure there were t-shirts i
remember
at one point i was selling them a cousin
was brought these books that they're
they were dating an fbi
person who had like all this access
right
and they looked up this is not good
hugely extended family tree
and they printed up a book that thick
and they started handing them out to
everybody to see who here's who you're
related to here's who you're related to
your dad's name was redacted everywhere
it's like black power is not everything
okay so what are you telling me is you
have multiple family members with
files in the fbi yeah i guess so yeah
yeah
so there were always like souvenirs and
things like that
just everybody's mug shots yeah here's
pudding in 98
99 and again in o2 holy [ __ ]
yeah what a tail um
let's see have you ever owned a chia pet
no
do you have a mag light flashlight
no you have flares in your car no
what players i don't have flares road
flares
once you work for the fire department
what the [ __ ] has road players
some people yeah if you're doing a bank
job or something
you're telling me you never you never
drove by somebody that was changing the
tire and they had like the flares out
and they were doing it right
it's garbage no i mean i barely have it
i barely know how to change this this is
a triple-a guy
right yeah yeah can we ask what kind of
car you drive now
wrangler okay that's trash
brand new i mean i've had it for a
couple years it was
four-door two-door now it's a four-door
but this is my third wrangler
man that's trashy yeah it's so weird
because you're like
absolutely no trash on certain on most
things and then the things you do go
trashy and you really
[ __ ] go into it yeah who has multiple
jeeps you buy one then realize what the
[ __ ]
and then you get a real car you're
talking down what color is the wrangler
don't say yellow
no the one i have now is gray when was
the last time you drove it without the
doors on it
oh it's been a while okay it's been a
while i mean i wouldn't i don't even
know if this four-door has had the doors
taken off
does your wife have a car yeah she
drives like a subaru like a regular car
yeah all right thank god yeah okay
is there any other addition like do you
have anything after market products or
anything tricked out on the wrangler
no do you have like the chrome grille
nothing do you do the jeep wave when you
see other people in a jeep
only if they initiate it i'm not going
to turn somebody's jeep wave down but i
won't
start it you know this is something i
might have done years ago
okay in my first even maybe my second
jeep
now that i'm on my third jeep it's like
do i need to wave to everybody
nothing drives me crazier than that the
[ __ ] jeep wave
could be jealousy i don't know yeah if
they initiate it though
i would never turn it down yeah yeah i
mean it's common courtesy yeah
hmm have you ever seen the harlem
globetrotters
no but in high school whoever the
bootleg version of the harlem
globetrotters is
there's a there's a lesser version no
there's none
yeah yeah yeah it's like it was just
your high school basketball thing
yeah there's a there's a there's a
lesser version of the harlem
globetrotters
and the generals the guys they beat up
on all the time it's like a totally
different
faction that just stole their entire act
the bronx tri-states
yeah and i've seen them they uh
in like my high school my high school
got them to come out and do like uh
you know fake harlem globetrotters
versus the teachers
gotcha you know game for the kids to all
come and
yeah so i saw that i saw them
but yeah so not only so i haven't seen
the harlem globetrotters but i have seen
well the trashy answer
yes that's that's that's what i'm saying
when he goes trashing he's like
yeah yeah now where were you guys where
will you guys go on vacation now
like as a family you your wife and the
kids what will you take them uh it's
been a really
i don't take them back down to kentucky
like if they've been down to this
the kids have my wife has okay and she
was
disgusting where is she from if you
don't mind me asking she's from
westchester okay
yeah yeah yeah she was i mean disgusted
to the point where
like she didn't like pudding no she was
i'd be nice enough guy just not uh yeah
no i mean like i
i like we had to stay in the same resort
resort yeah yeah really stayed
rooms still smell like cigarettes in 20
whatever it was probably 18 17 16
even in 2015 for a hotel room to smell
like still smell like cigarettes it's
alarming
that's a tough one yeah it's a tough one
to get down yeah
well we we found by from doing the show
the south plays by their own rules
yeah you have to grade them on a curve
yeah it's very the south does whatever
the [ __ ] they want yeah what she said
when she was like oh it's a resort and i
was like
yeah and she was like oh like can i get
like uh a massage spa
like i mean i mean like it'll spread you
with the hose if you want yeah
if pudding gets a couple of drinks in
them don't worry yeah he gets hands all
yeah plenty of guys there will give you
a rub down where will you go now
wherever you guys go what's your typical
summer vacation
uh i think the last time i took my wife
on vacation
was when she was pregnant with our
two-year-old
and i took her to disney world but we
didn't bring our now
four-year-old it was just us and also i
didn't realize until we got there that
pregnant women can't ride rides
oh my god so it's like you wait here
sweetheart wait a minute
what'd you do with your four-year-old
left him with my parents he was
two or you know one and a half two years
old and how come he didn't take him
because it would have been too much see
again but the adults going
to disney
a pregnant wife pregnant wife at disney
and we didn't
i didn't know she couldn't ride the
rides until we got there she can't i
didn't even consider it like nothing
across your head that she can't go
upside down in a roller coaster
consider it
[Laughter]
yeah here look i i told her look half
the experience
is the line yeah right i mean looking at
the ride's over in 90 seconds right
right so hey honey you want to go to
florida and watch me have fun
yeah oh that's beautiful yeah i'm not
i'm not but i'm also not a big vacation
i have to be dragged out on vacation man
do you remember what your first pick
when you got your first big contract or
whatever when things started really
working out when you were younger
do you remember what you bought was it
was there like a big purchase a first
purchase
a big tv or a jet something like that
yeah probably a a a tv i mean i held out
for a long time
with the tvs getting hand-me-downs from
people i was rocking a tube tv
you get that from your dad way back yeah
yeah yeah
yeah to the point where like uh in in
the opium anthony days
they were busting my balls for not
having a very nice television set
and russell simmons came in studio and
they showed they were like
russell like see sam over there this is
his tv he gave me a hundred dollars on
the spot
a new tv right now so yeah i think it
was uh
yeah it was a big tv when we moved into
the house that we're in now
i put a giant tv in the basement which
is my where i put
my studios there all my stuff is there
nice studio by the way very nice studio
and it i mean it was months before my
wife came down and she was like
it's bigger than the tv in the living
room what are you doing why would you
put that down here
but yeah it's probably probably a tv you
know putting the down payment on the
house
sure yeah yeah so you're you're you're
conservative when it comes to that
you're not out there blowing money i try
to i mean look
sometimes we get a little crazy during
the pandemic
i paid a whole bunch of money for a
shirt that mick foley wore at
wrestlemania 2000
check please can i ask you what a whole
bunch of money is
all right so we'll and we'll wrap it up
here
it's more than nine dollars it's too
much money
i'm sitting there right and i i was i
had a show on the wwe network
right and i would have like wrestlers on
every episode and i
asked mick foley to do it he was like
yeah of course and we're talking
and one of the things he's plugging and
mick foley loves a dollar you know he
loves it
yeah so one of the things he's plugging
is he's gonna go do this uh
live auction on facebook that this
company's gonna do
and and he told me and he goes and i'll
just tell you sam
i found the shirt that i wore
in the main event of wrestlemania 2000
oh and i'm going to auction it off
and i was like and uh where was this
auction gonna take place
yeah and so the thing that he was
plugging on the show
i just logged on to it on the facebook
page
and like he's like here's the shirt and
so i'd start bidding
and they're like sam roberts samurai
like is that
sam roberts who works for wwe he's just
he just bit it like the guy
was on his show plugging this thing he's
he's just bidding on this now kid loser
for real man
yeah and so yeah you know eighteen
hundred dollars is the type of money
that you'll spend he's only been in the
wrestlemania main event one time that's
the only time you were a green flannel
so it's very distinct
wow and yeah i don't know how to call
this guy
yeah what are you nuts babe babe it's
game war
yeah that's right and she go oh yeah so
i put she had to be pissed
they're like so i'm doing it on the
facebook thing and she's next to me
and so i'm like typing in and like the
volume's up because i'm listening to
them on video as they're like doing this
thing
they're like oh sam roberts just put in
eighteen hundred bucks
and my wife is like you did
what i got just trust me as i take
another sam roberts i swear i go like
this
he only main event at wrestlemania one
time
and it's the only time he wore green
jay this this this shirt is going to go
for a lot more than 1800
all i'm doing is boosting it up for my
pal mick i just want to make sure that
it goes at the right price
and as i'm explaining it to her like
i'll never actually have to pay this
so right
don't you have breast milk to make
[Laughter]
you don't know garbage across
the board but it's not across the board
that's the thing it's not across the
board
this guy's a [ __ ] class act has he
made a couple of mistakes from time to
time
sure like i said everybody gets a couple
mulligans everywhere
you know what i mean we're all friends
here holy everybody's got a past
yeah i'm saying garbage but i mean the
big holy shirt happened like within the
last six months
[Laughter]
why would you do that why would you say
that i'm telling you
see call me an [ __ ] um
look the banana pudding the person
pudding
shirt what's person the guy named
the multiple multiple jeep
wranglers you gotta you gotta you gotta
but you're just you're just discrediting
england boom you're discrediting
that's his name he had no choice in that
college was a tough look too now
but that was a business decision that
set him off on a rocket ship of success
that's true the jacket and that there's
innovation behind that
innovation who puts a [ __ ] who pieces
together
a major in college yeah that's insane
yeah just drop out like a gentleman
i mean you gotta you gotta you gotta
take the the points from both columns
right i feel like sometimes
we look at the trash column and we just
start ignoring all the great things that
we like
i'm trying to i'm trying we get your old
man in here
class across the board i'm not saying
that yeah
the apple that fell from the tree so far
he rolled you rolled a little throw it
get broke i'll give you that i don't
think you're not fully trash
you fell from a classy tree and you
rolled a little bit yeah you rolled a
little bit
okay but clay classic i mean he's a
classy guy he can walk in both worlds
my vote doesn't count but i say 60 40
these guys glass yeah
60 40 60 40 60 40 60 40. yeah let me ask
you that what was the
cause you made me think of something
what was you say was the most classy
event you've ever been to in your whole
life
like a black tie affair wedding or like
a fundraiser
well
who's the most famous person you've been
around in a social setting
that would that would work as a question
i mean any presidents anything like that
i'm related to thomas jefferson hmm
it's cancer culture that's not a good
look though
[Laughter]
should we uh 20 years ago that's a good
that's a good plug
i might get you into the resort down in
kentucky
then i'm gonna fly in williamsburg
brooklyn my friend yeah
um related to thomas jefferson yeah you
know i mean
everybody says that though i know how
can you prove it
you know i'm gonna say what am i gonna
tell you i'm gonna tell you stone cold
steve austin or not
you know i mean what am i gonna tell you
here i'm not trying to put myself in a
hole
[Laughter]
what can i tell you when you're talking
to me about black tie affairs and the
first thing that pops into my mind is
the wwe hall of fame ceremony am i gonna
say that out loud
that's [ __ ] awesome that's i mean
it's classic just so happens to be the
world that he works in it's cla
dude a whole any remove that you say
rock and roll hall of fame yes
nfl hall i'm giving it to him i think
that's classy class
man he's really putting up all right
well let's here we go we got one or two
from the patreon that we we always do
uh when you join the patreon we will
answer your garbage questions so let's
run through these real quick
yeah this uh have you ever this is from
mike
ever fished off a bridge yeah
i knew this kid was going to fall apart
i knew it i think we could stop
that i mean i was a determining factor
i mean i'm trash and i've never fished
fished off a bridge stone cold who do
you think brought the bait
i've you know i've got made out of a
live bait vending machine buddy i was
just talking about that a couple
episodes ago yeah shout out to a good
bait vending machine
paducah has tons of them yeah i'm sure
for lunch
is that it are you satisfied i mean
that's yeah that's perfect that's the
perfect way to go
out i mean we [ __ ] [ __ ] mike on
the patreon
[ __ ] his head turned a mist smart
people they're smart people
because i was thinking as you were going
i was like if he follows up on that
question i could be in trouble he didn't
follow up i'm like all right
i'm not going to give it to him no just
leave it at that yeah ah what an episode
sam thank you so much is there anything
you want the folks out there
to know that you have coming up that
they might not know or uh you know jim
and sam
obviously on serious xm in the mornings
then my youtube channel is youtube.com
or i do
sam roberts now every friday night live
awesome unbelievable
thank you so much man this was this was
by the way my youtube numbers
true numbers everywhere but he's been
doing good for like 15 years this guy
killing it yeah can't be what he got for
him uh just make sure as always you can
subscribe uh on itunes you can leave
rate review that helps us out with the
charts youtube as sam said
through the roof uh also patreon.com and
then live shows guys we're coming to a
bunch of cities get some [ __ ] tickets
baby
guys we love you we'll see you next week
peace